I'm glad you came to hear about the new parser
coming to Node.
About who I am, I'm Fedor Indutny.
Here's my Twitter and GitHub handles which
are the same.
And I write code at PayPal.
You might know me by this dark avatar I use
on GitHub and Twitter and practically everywhere
else.
For today talk, the slides and the presentations
are already up online.
If you would like, you can scan the QR code
and open your browser and follow along as
I'm going to present the topic.
Which is llhttp.
The new HTTP protocol parser for Node.js.
This has deep roots into the history of Node.js.
And it would be hard if not impossible not
to mention the history while describing.
Of course, Node.js is used to load for the
front-end tooling.
But originally historically it started as
the backend platform.
It was exclusively about building asynchronous
HTTP servers.
And the creator of Node, HTTP parser is what
started as node.
There's presentations on the importance and
role and structure.
It's a power Node.js event loop and it's key
ever since they set up the node.
And you might remember if there's a dependency,
however, it is not.
As an HTTP parser, it has all the dependencies
that Node ever had.
It leads all the dependencies in Node.
Initially it was inspired by mongrel, a Ruby
web server with its own parser created by
web show.
And later, parts
Nginx code introduced in HTTP parser, the
original one.
And, of course, the code itself.
The parser has been with us since 2009.
It's been more than ten years.
And in effect, Node itself has been introduced
that the very conference ten years ago by
Ryan.
So, it's kind of a jubilee for both of those
projects.
And I wrote another HTTP parser to replace
the original parser.
So, why would anyone want to get rid of such
a library?
Of course, it's a fantastic library.
It has been with us for ten years.
It should have been worked fine.
And it has many users inside of the Node.js
community as well.
For example, Android proxy by Google.
They use it for parsing HTTP requests and
it's quite a popular project as well.
What makes this parser great and why did it
stay?
First, good enough performance.
It takes quite a bit of time to invoke a C
function, and parser is written in C. It takes
way less time to parse the requests.
I'm going to elaborate on it a bit later in
this presentation.
But for NodeJS purposes, it's very good performance.
Couldn't be better.
It also supports a lot of clients and servers
that violate the HTTP specification.
There are way too many of them out on the
Internet.
You would be surprised how many.
And, of course, it was very important for
early adoption of NodeJS.
Because in 2009 there was even more such clients
and servers out there.
Another point is that original parser has
a lot of test suites.
So, over ten years Ryan, Ben and other maintainers
of the project, including myself, have wrote
quite a comprehensive test suite that covers
almost every aspect of HTTP specification.
So, the parser is welltested.
So, that was the good points of the original
parser.
Now we come to other points.
Unfortunately, with the HTTP library the code
became quite rigid.
It became impossible to move things around,
to make significant changes to it.
And as a consequence of this, it became impossible
to maintain this library efficiently.
Furthermore, as one of the maintainers of
the project, I have to constantly relearn
and get familiar with the parts of the codebase
that I was previously familiar with before.
And I did it on every pull request and still
I wasn't sure if the code is going to run
in the way I expected it to run.
So, it could introduce some unexpected behavior.
Or maybe a security vulnerability as well.
Which is obviously bad.
It doesn't help either that most NodeJS users
and developers are familiar with JavaScript
and are more comfortable with it than they
are with C. So, there was not too many people
interested in working on this HTTP parser.
With all this in mind, several years ago I
set out on a quest it make the library better
and maybe a bit faster in the process.
First attempts were quite conservative.
So, I tried to stay with existing code as
much as possible.
And some of them were successful.
Like replacing the parser state machine with
a cross, and using it consistently not only
improved the code, but also made it faster.
Which was nice.
Other attempts were a complete disaster.
I tried to move those states into a separated
function and just called them from the loop
so each state would return the next state
that was supposed to be executed and then
the loop would run the function for it.
This completely ruins the performance and
I never contributed or sent it to the string.
From this attempt was success or failure,
the conclusion was clear.
It was hard to make an improvement while staying
with the existing codebase.
There was no requirement to use as much code
as possible, it was no longer required to
make it in the same programming language as
before.
Why not develop it in JavaScript or maybe
TypeScript instead?
And, of course, JavaScript performance is
quite great.
But you wouldn't be surprised that it's slower
than C and takes a lot of effort to reach
comparable performances in the C libraries
when you write programs in JavaScript.
Takes a lot of effort.
But it's possible.
So, I wanted to get this performance optimization
out of consideration.
And also, I decided to just define the parser
in TypeScript and still compile it down to
the C library.
So, the end result would be C library that
was used in Node and other projects.
Which was great because existing users of
HTTP parser this way would be able to transition
their code to the new parser and hopefully
the process and the performance would not
degrade so much because in the end it's the
same programming language.
It would have good chances of being the same
speed.
So, llhttp is the next major version of HTTP
parser.
It has the same core principles and similar
API, which is almost identical.
And the way they work, is they scan one character
at a time.
And during the process they change the internal
state and they could add a header fields or
maybe header values and later on body.
I'm not sure if we're going to wait for this.
It's quite slow.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think you probably understand what it means
now.
At least to some extent.
So, this can by the virtue of this one scan
the parser can work without buffering anything
at all.
So, it doesn't allocate memory itself.
And it creates especially for request bodies
because it could just need the slices of original
buffers that came from that work instead of
allocating the coping data.
So, in the core principle of the HTTP parser,
it's not copying.
That's important.
And as soon as any amount of data arrives
via a request or a single byte of request,
HTTP parser is ready to process it.
And it will be possibly partial because it
will be health requests.
And the header names, we are just seeing in
this animation.
In the original version of the parser, this
scan was quite naturally implemented foreloop
over the input.
Just going by the input bytebybyte and doing
some syncs.
What it did, it was described by a huge which
statement or all possible parsing state.
Whether it's a header name, header value,
whether it's value of content lengths header,
it was all described by the switch statement,
and they represented different states of the
state machine.
All of this lived in a single function or
1,000 lines of code which is quite a terrible
idea.
So, an obvious improvement would be to break
this switch into pieces and make it such that
each piece has precise action.
It's sort of a unique philosophy, I guess.
So, it would be just exactly about doing one
small thing at a time.
Go to statements would be used to jump between
states.
There would not be as much need for this foreloop,
at least not as much.
With all this in mind, how do I approach this
process?
I developed a domainspecific language, DSL,
and created a compiler around it, LL parse,
so, again, double L. And this compiler is
used to describe the parsing states in terms
of these actions that they perform.
So, each state would have several actions
assigned to them and they would perform them
and move on to the next state.
Because of this llparse is quite a general
compiler, it can be used for other protocols
as well.
It works better for textual protocols, but
I think it's useful.
Original parser suffered from a surplus of
handwritten code.
I have selected a few actions that were repeated
most in the original library and had DSL around
them.
The idea here is that I wanted the description
of the new parser to be concise.
So, I wanted to write code with less lines
and less signals than possible.
I wanted to move the most common iterations
inside of the compiler so that the rest would
have to do the work all over again and the
original parser.
Here were a few that the compiler supports.
One is match.
It takes a sequence, or a character of bytes
and it tries to match them from the input.
For example, it could be keep alive, which
is the value of the headernamed connection.
It's quite a common header and very important.
So, it could match this sequence.
And when it does, move to the next state by
taking the reference to this state.
And other times the parser needs to check
the next character in the incoming data without
actually consuming it.
And it could be used for this.
Takes a single character and mentions it and
moves on without moving the input stream.
And speaking of headers, headers like lengths,
they have internal values which frankly described
by strings, it's a contextual protocol.
The new parser has to be able to parse the
integer strings.
And the way I decided to do it was to implement
a select method in DSL which takes a map as
an input.
And this map has sequences or characters as
keys.
And the integers as values.
So, it tries to map this sequence to the integers
and just passes values along to the next state.
The next state could be storing integers inside
some property of the structure, or maybe walking
a user code back with them.
Speaking of callbacks, there is one special
type of callback.
It is very important in the life span of both
original and the new HTTP parser.
During their executions they need ranges of
data.
For example, header names, or headers are
in this way.
And begin that we have a stream of data that
comes to the parser, we have to be able to
mark some certain place inside of this stream
as the beginning of this range.
And then at some other point later on we want
to set it as an ending of the range.
So, between those beginning and ending, or
you can see, our beginning and ending.
Between them the callback is going to be invoked
for every byte.
And it's really, really useful for header
names, header values and bodies, and other
things that could be needed that spans the
ranges of input.
Of course, there are a couple of important
actions that I have not needed in previous
slides that are actually mandatory to have
in this state.
They call otherwise and skip to.
And those specify which states of the parser
should be reached next if nothing else matches
inside of the current state.
So, in this example, the input would be A.
The parser would move to the A state, and
for B, move to B and C or D or E or whatever
is later.
It would move to some other state.
Skip to is quite similar.
It's the same thing but consumes the character
from the input stream.
Otherwise, it does not change the input stream
at all.
It just moves on.
So, that was a bit of description maybe too
concise to be useful of DSL.
And with this DSL in mind, llhttp becomes
a type Script program.
This program uses it to describe the actions
and input as said before.
Because it's a TypeScript program, or JavaScript
program, really, I could split it into several
sub modules and use them efficiently.
And each submodule could have the subparser.
This is what I use in HTTP.
I have a separate parser inside of it and
can use it and run it separately and can be
used separately as well as a library if anyone
wants it.
Llparse compile this is TypeScript program
down to C. And that's the main action of it.
Know that because it uses a stable DSL, oh,
sorry, just uses DSL, the parser doesn't need
to do any parsing.
It's done automatically by the JS engine.
So, V8 does it for us.
V8 does this itself internally.
Llparse builds a graph of state which I will
try to show you.
It looks kind of terrible.
But I probably can zoom in.
Yeah.
So, yeah, hear, how it looks like in practice.
I can probably actually show you something
more useful.
So, here on the right you see ACL buy check
out this.
Mobile names supported by parser.
And the name is matched in this of the input.
It will store the integer and coding as a
method inside those internal properties of
parsers.
It works this way more or less.
I guess with a that means is the kind of graph
is looking awesome.
So, that's one of the reasons to have it.
And another reason to have it is that llparse
can do static analysis on this graph.
Before in original parsers there was no way
to reason about the states automatically.
So, it was all described manually inside of
the parser.
There was just a lot of C code.
And there was no way to analyze it and to
do any optimizations for checks.
What I can to in llparse is check the code
for absence of infant loops which is possible
due to otherwise so, they could be combined
together.
Not just making any progress over the input
and just being in indefinitely.
It's important to check this statically because
there might be an array of conditions that
could trigger it.
It might not be immediately verifiable with
the test suite.
Speaking of optimizations, the parser could
do peephole optimizations.
That's a fancy name for just combining similar
states together into one.
This way the amount of code is reduced, and
also the compiler sorry, programmer has a
lot more freedom and development with the
parser because they don't have to think about
doing these optimizations manually in their
code.
So, as I said, the DSL is quite stable for
llparse.
So, same program could be compared to different
outputs.
At this moment, C and the code is wellsupported.
And the code was kind of before, it was supported
before the C. So, that's the reason why both
projects have double L in their names.
Kind of a historical reason.
But in the end when I ran benchmarks, this
tree C compiler worked better than the code
which I spent several weeks on.
It was surprising for me, maybe shocking.
I had a few months to think about it.
Yeah.
And speaking of performance, you might be
wondering how fast this new parser is given
that it is not handwritten at all.
But, of course, despite the maintenance issues,
as I said before, the original parser has
quite a bit of improvements.
They're good enough, still very good.
It would have been very unreasonable to replace
it with something that performed significantly
worse.
So, ll shipping is not handwritten, it's not
hand optimized.
And when I ran benchmarks, I discovered that
it runs twice as fast as the original parser.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And here is the actual benchmark numbers.
So, as you can see, both those numbers did
quite well.
As it presents a number of requests per second
that each parser can take.
And this way both parsers run in microseconds.
You wouldn't ever see this on the profile
logs.
Just impossible to see it.
And, of course, it's important to note as
well that llhttp is more than two times faster
than the original parser.
But no one hardly cares about it.
This llhttp parser is a default in Node version
12.
If you are using the latest Node, I hope you
do, you are already running this.
And even more, you have a reason to blame
me for any kinds of HTTP problems that you
have.
So, feel free to do so and it would be rightful.
Please open GitHub.
Don't just brag on Twitter how bad I am.
And tag me on GitHub.
I will be happy to look into it and fix it
as soon as possible.
As I said before, over ten years originally
the parser has accumulated a comprehensive
test suite.
It would be really unwise to get rid of it
and just start it over.
So, I ported all the original tests to mark
down.
And the new ones.
And here they are described by the markdown
files.
So, they completed, and I encourage you to
take a look at them if you want.
Because I find them the most I'm using part
of the project that worked on.
Yes.
They're really, really fun.
I'm going to give a bit more time because
I see that some people scanned
the codes.
Okay.
So, that makes it.
And each markdown file contains several tests.
They are separated by the headings.
So, it's quite easy to read.
And even easier to contribute.
In fact, they had one contributor that submitted
a test without asking a question how to do
so.
And I don't know that many projects that uses
a test system that's easy to contribute.
And furthermore, each test has an actual description
inside of them.
They have code chunks inside of markdown,
code chunk for expected output, and between
those you can put just any text you want.
You can put hyperlinks, you can put images.
You can put GIFs of pets doing stuff.
So, it's quite a nice way of writing tests.
And it especially works well for HTTP because
it's the contextual protocol.
And you can see in C where it's actually inside
the test suite.
Yeah.
So, here's been the presence of the parser
and the history of it.
So, naturally I would like to talk about what's
coming next.
And there is room for future improvements
with regards to doing more static checks in
this graph I'm showing to you and doing more
performance optimizations.
There are forks of original parsers that use
CPUspecific vector instructions which are
really, really, fast.
They perform better than both.
Not much use for this speed bump for Node.
But nevertheless, there's no reason to not
explore it.
I probably should do it, or I would love someone
do it for me to do some.
Quite ashamedly, the project is not well documented.
It has quite a bit of information describing
the API of llparse, but it's scattered through
several dependencies and could be made more
accessible.
I could use help with this and I'm sure some
people might find this quite entertaining
as well because there's a lot of interesting
moments in this parser, in this code.
Finally, it would be fascinating to see different
types of parsers implemented on top of llparse.
Two examples that I have in mind, SMTP and
protocols, they are contextual and could be
implemented in llparse.
I really look forward to either working on
this or helping someone with this.
And, yeah.
Here is a link to the ll repos.
It's quite easy to find on GitHub.
Just under the Node.js organization.
GitHub.com/Node.js/ et cetera /llhttp.
So, I guess that's it.
Thank you so much for listening.